today is 2 2 20 22. it's a big day for
weddings you know more than 75 000
couples said i do last year in las vegas
the alcoholman is live to share what
couples can look forward to this month
and this year tell us all about it
bianca
hey good morning sheri so you know folks
love their numerology so today is a big
day
for weddings so grab the bouquet or if
you've caught it maybe today is the time
that you go ahead and tie the knot so
tons of people are going to be headed to
the altar to tie the knot today so we
continue to be the wedding capital of
the world our marriage rate here in las
vegas is 29 per thousand which is the
largest clark county is expected to
reach its 5 millionth wedding since 1909
this month the biggest day so far was
back in uh july 7 2007 that was a big
day there they were able to complete 4
500
weddings
marriage tourism is a big business here
in las vegas it generates about two
billion dollars and it's a 20 and per
couple is actually there is about 27 000
that they spend that includes the
wedding hotels other activities for the
weekend
this is has always been known as kind of
quick and easy you can make it simple
for couples you can focus on yourselves
instead of on your big wedding party
that stresses you out and turns you into
bridezilla and so that's been true
pretty much since the early 30s when
nevada made their marriage lies easier
some other big days for weddings this
month include february 14th of course
valentine's day and get this tuesday
february 22nd
yeah that's 2 22
22. what an amazing day to call your
anniversary and then another day another
big day february 20th that's a sunday
2022. so we've got some big dates this
week and again they hope to reach that 5
millionth wedding this month i'm pretty
sure we're going to reach it but coming
up in the next half hour we're going to
talk about other ways to reignite your
wrong bands because this is the month of
love bianca holmen live local now love